alright differentiate and graph
differentiator graph so this is actually
not that much a different shape right
the derivative of all this function
right channel okay we would say that
that x squared minus X right you might
call that the inside function so we'll
call it that
okay so that means that your derivative
here it's gonna be f dash on F okay sir
but remember this is 2x minus 1 and
you've got your x squared minus X that's
it okay there's no certifying I mean I
could factorize that but there's not
much point okay why did we find the
derivative again what's the point
so the first stationary points right
okay so I would say stationary points
exist when um this thing is equal to
zero okay now because it's particularly
easy function I just want to find out
when this is zero so as usual I
disregard that denominator okay I'm
looking at the numerator yes
when is the numerator equal to zero its
when X is equal to 1/2 right okay so so
far so good
hey everything seems to be going normal
and then you would start to graph it but
as you own as you start to graph it you
come up with a problem so let's have a
look at what this thing is gonna look
like how it's going to behave
okay this is a log function right let me
go back to what we look at before if you
just take a vanilla standard log
function without any reader stuff in
there right what's the domain of such a
function what's the domain
well what values of x does this function
exists what's it look like this is log X
right and you've got your asymptotes
yeah okay so anything greater than zero
but I kind of get to zero itself because
of an asymptote there so let's say the
domain is extrinsic okay no that
corresponds to is if okay if I were to
give you you write this function right
I'm just translating what this means is
e to the power of Y should be equal to X
right e to some power with equal to X
and as I change what the power is the
value of x change right
but there's no power that I can put in
here which would make e to the power of
that a negative number okay e to the
power of naught right let's see the
power it's just as I go bigger numbers
in the power of two three four five a
hundred okay
he just gets bigger and bigger to make
up huge numbers what even either power
when I go in the other direction
negative okay e to the power of minus 10
minus 100 minus 1,000 what happens to
the number it gets really small okay
just cuz you get one over e to the power
that gets tiny
but it never goes negative right okay so
therefore this is the domain where it's
fancy
but when I come over to this function I
don't have just standard on X right
instead of X I've got that sir if I were
you got the domain right then that
inside function that has to be positive
has to follow the same rules
establish that here okay x squared minus
X is greater than zero come in so when
you think about this what kind of graph
can that be x times X minus one
what's it look like it's a parabola okay
looks like this X means a real zero X
minus one means a root at one so this
graph so where is the domain of my
actual function the domain of this
function corresponds to when this is
greater than zero okay so I guess I
would say the domain is X is by the
looks of things less than zero or it's
greater than what do we say the other it
was one okay sir hold on a second this
causes problems because you're looking
when you found your stationary point x
equals a half which looks like it's
about there and it's not in the domain
the stationary point is not in the
domain what does that mean hmm I'm just
gonna let that question simmer for a
minute okay because it doesn't have a
good obvious answer at least I don't so
if I don't have any stationary points
that are actually in my domain the graph
that I'm gonna come up with also will
not have you statement now let's come
back to this okay
um being that you've got this kind of
derivative okay I can make some pretty
good assumptions about the shape of this
graph based on okay is it decreasing or
is it increasing all these kinds of
things okay so what you'll find as you
test some values is that remember I
can't go past zero
to the left of x equals zero your
function is look at that okay when X is
negative x is negative
what would the numerator be like what
value really we're talking take would be
also negative right so it might be say x
equals minus one so this would be minus
2 minus 1 is minus 3 and then what do
you get with one of them
this negative will turn into a positive
right so negative kind of a positive the
gradient that's what that's what this
thing tells you the gradients negative
which means it's decreasing as I get
closer to the origin going going from
left to right okay
what's happening into the gradient past
the gradient change what's it
approaching this is the question of
asking what's the limit as H approaches
zero
now another word for this already I'd
like you to go my only graph and show
you okay but I want you to prove it for
yourself because this is how I knew what
I was doing and as a expert to 0 and
these values get very small okay the
whole thing is becoming a very very
large negative number very very large
negative them Oh what would that mean
for the graph what does it say to you
when your gradient is a very very large
negative oh it's really steep and it's a
decreasing as I approach zero okay so
this is the kind of shape you get I
can't cross this asymptote and then you
get another asymptote and you can again
check out your own derivative taken
limit as X approaches should label this
x equals 1 you get the same thing except
in Reverse it's approaching a very very
large positive number so that's why it's
increasing its increasing your a really
steep rate hmm now what happens if you
because when you're graphing like say a
rational function right and you might
get up here's an asymptote here's
another one and you've got one part
another part usually assume you'll have
another part in here that's a reasonable
assumption to make
so what's happening in this case you
take
yeah
like we could I mean based on this right
they might they might do something up
here it'd be kind of weird though as
well because this seems to be increasing
and this seems to increase it so maybe
it should be like decreasing what's
going on now the answer is at least on
this graph nothing's going because we
said for the domain of this function is
only to the left of there and to the
right of here okay so actually I'm
finished with one exception I should
probably find what these guys are okay
can we do that together how would you
work them out how do you usually find
x-intercepts like was your own so
there's why okay so I'll say log of x
squared minus X is equal to zero
no one set again careful think this is
this is log may seem right so when
you're when you're going back and forth
okay yes so the base of a log equation
will become the base of an index
equation I rewrite oh right so I'm gonna
get e to the power of 0 is equal to x
squared minus X so then this is just 1
ok so when you go through that I'll save
you some time it's you can't factorize
it nicely
you've got minus B plus or minus the
square root of b squared minus 4ac chins
up you fire at least if I didn't write
on to to air okay so when you look at
that this must be in the 1 plus and this
must be the one layers
that's it now there's just one more
question
I have if all your if all you want to do
is just draw the graph and get yet four
marks and get parameters okay we're
finished however I post your question I
wonder if you have any idea of an answer
yeah which is what's happening in here I
wonder what's going on I said it's
outside the domain so we haven't drawn
anything right and yet I feel like
something should be happening because
the function doesn't exist there but the
derivative does usually way more used to
functions that are a bit the other way
around
okay so if you remember this guy the
cube root of x should be the minister
you member what that looks like
looks like that
okay there's a function or what about
the absolute value of x now these two
functions they exist at the origin but
they derivative doesn't okay like we
asked the question what's the derivative
at this point is it one or is it minus
one and so it's neither doesn't exist
but here you've got kind of a reverse in
the function doesn't it is first
derivative does now there is a graph to
this okay I told you it's just not gonna
be on this graph his problem is come in
because what I need to do to actually
draw these in between passes that have
to come off the board because I need to
third dimension to handle this because
actually some numbers will make this
work
it just is that they're not real numbers
that's all they're conflicts imaginary
stuck in there which makes it work okay
except this is just 2d so I got my ex
and I got my wife and I would need a Zed
I would need it to sort of come out of
the more often an angle that makes sense
anyway so there's just to make you think
that yeah this is the graph does
actually have a behavior in here and
this is what governs it it's a little
bit like you know the formula for
Fibonacci numbers right this stuff
actually it's very convenient looks like
that it's stuff going on that makes the
the term the nth term formula that makes
it work just you can't see it so this
stuff going on the graph is doing
something it's just invisible tools